[Captions by Y Translator]
[Music]
Guys, we did it!
10 million subscribers.
I started this channel back in 2010,
and back then, I only started it
as a place to upload videos
of projects that I was working on.
See, back in 2008-2009,
during the recession,
there was a lot of
real estate foreclosures,
and talks of depression,
and I wanted to be the guy
who would be prepared
for any emergency.
So, I was taking apart microwaves,
and playing with electronics.
To just try and figure out
how a society worked,
and how to reverse engineer that at home.
And, so my YouTube channel was
really just a place to start
uploading videos that I was making
as I was tinkering with these things.
Some people wonder where the
name 'The King of Random' came from,
and it really was from
a person called Mike Lyman,
a friend of my brother's,
who just always happened to be there
every time I was coming over to show
my brother the new thing that I had made.
He just look at me and say like,
"Dude, you're like the King of Random,"
and that name, you
know, it kind of stuck.
I kind of liked it.
I kind of didn't,
but when I originally
started my YouTube channel,
because I didn't have a purpose in it,
I didn't know what username
to come up with,
and so some of you subscribers
who've been around since the beginning
might remember the channel name
was actually 01032010814,
which seems like
a totally random number.
But literally, that was the date and time
that I started my YouTube channel.
It was January 3rd, 2010
at 8:14 in the morning.
So that was my channel name,
and unfortunately, at that time,
I could not go back
and change my channel name,
so I was stuck with it.
But then, Google+ came along,
and I could create a Google+ page
and change my name, and so
the only available name that I could
change it to that wasn't already taken
was 'The King of Random.'
So, that's where
'The King of Random' came from.
That's why we've been
'The King of Random' ever since.
[Music]
A few of you have been asking
to meet The King of Random team.
Well, we've seen your comments, so let
me go ahead and introduce you to them.
Of course, I'm Grant.
For some of you new subscribers,
you may not know who I am.
I started this channel originally,
and dedicated seven years of my life to it.
>> I'm Nate.
I build things, and then I film them?
>> I'm Mark.
You guys may know me, I've been working
on the channel for almost two years now.
>> Risking personal safety.
>> Yeah, I'm the videographer.
>> I'm Richard,and I'm
the one doing the animation.
>> I'm Hunter, I edit the videos,
and I manage the post-production team.
>> Hey guys, I'm Josh, and I do
some of the graphic design,
and video editing for the channel,
and I kind of run the social media as well.
>> I'm Lean.
I edit the videos.
I also made the intro stickers.
>> I'm Dan.
I edit videos and work on special effects.
>> Guys, we're here in Alaska right now.
I'm with my wife, and we're watching
this from Alaska, rolling over right now.
10 million, it's incredible.
>> It's amazing.
>> That was big jump.
>> 992.
>> We got 8 subscribers left.
>> 8 more to go!
>> Here we go!
>> Come on. Come on.
Come on. Come on.
Come on.
>> Yeah!
>> 993.
We're here with Grandpa.
Got my wife.
>> Hi!
>> A couple of my little boys.
We're in Alaska.
We got six subscribers left to go.
>> Six to go.
Six to go.
>> It's at 994.
We just have six more.
This is intense.
This is crazy.
I'm so excited.
>> Come on.
Come on, people.
>> Oh, they're just leaving us hanging.
>> Subscribe.
Subscribe.
>> 995.
So close.
>> Five more.
Five more.
Oh, we lost one.
>> Jamin, you gotta come see this.
997, three more.
Just three more.
>> Three. Just three more.
>> Just three more guys.
>> Oh, that was a big jump down.
>> Now, six more.
>> Come on you guys, you can do it!
>> 995.
>> Okay, what's next?
>> Oh!
>> Oh. Snap!
>> Do it! Do it!
>> That's it.
>> That was amazing!
>> Whoa!
>> We did it.
>> 10, 000, 022.
>> We love you guys.
10 million subscribers.
That's amazing!
>> Thank you!
Thank you!
In 2012, I decided to try a quest.
A quest for discovery,
and this was a hundred projects
that I wanted to do
to reverse engineer society.
You know, whether it's based
on electronics, magnets,
purifying water,
using sunlight to, you know,
melt steel or concrete,
or cook food or things of that nature.
I was gonna make 100 videos
based on self-reliance,
mechanical engineering,
principles of physics,
and really do it as a
learning process for myself.
I wanted to teach myself
how these things worked,
and once figured it out,
turned it into video,
and put it on this YouTube channel.
Now, fast-forward about three years,
because it took three years
for me to finish making
those hundred videos,
and by then, I think our channel
had four million subscribers.
We'd been featured on Dr. Oz.
>> This is why you are The King of Random.
>> Good Morning America.
We've had episodes
put on the Discovery Channel,
and it's really just opened so many doors.
When I look at that number,
it was fantastic.
But it didn't really click for me
until I started going outside,
you know, going shopping,
or going to the places I'd always gone.
But now, people are
starting to recognize me.
Ask for my picture,
ask for my autograph,
and I tell you, that felt really weird.
Because who am I?
I'm just a guy in my basement,
playing with stuff,
and people are asking for my autograph.
So that was a really crazy shift
that happened about
two and a half years ago.
>> Alright guys, pizza's here.
Looks pretty impressive.
>> It's actually really big.
I mean, that's my hand to scale, and we're
counting on you guys to polish this off.
>> Especially you Josh, it's all yours.
>> I'm the current host
of The King of Random,
and I also do most of the
researching, prototyping,
and building for all of the projects.
>> And he is really good.
I don't think I could have found
anybody better to fill this role.
He has exceeded my expectations.
Nate, you make me very proud.
>> Oh, we needed that face.
So, when we're getting ready for a shoot,
I always try to think of like
all the options of shots I can get,
and what will look best
to make these videos stand out.
I love doing epic shots,
like with the flamethrower,
showing the flames, and the different
colors like when it goes green, or...
I'm like not an on-camera person.
>> [inaudible]
>> I love it when you guys
comment on like,
really awesome shots that are in videos.
It just makes me feel better
that I've done a better job.
>> One thing that gets me really excited
at work is knowing that I have to be
more creative,
and random in my outputs.
>> So, I've been working
at The King of Random
for about a year and a half now,
and I've edited I think 292 videos.
>> You know, I really try to
have fun with the social posts.
The things on Instagram,
stories and all that.
I try to put little Easter eggs,
or a little fun elements in them
for you guys to see and find.
>> I get excited when I get the chance
to work on a weapons project,
or when I get the chance
to add some special effects.
>> I get excited when viewers
catch the Easter eggs that we
editors put in the videos, and make
fun of them in the comments.
>> For example, on the colored
hydrophobics sand video,
there's two frames where
it flashes a certain somebody's face,
but reading the comments on that video,
there was a lot of people that caught it,
and it was really fun to go
through and read all of those.
>> I think one of the
funniest comments I ever saw was,
I was scrolling through,
and somebody left this comment like,
"We don't miss you at all Grant,
because Nate is actually better than you anyway."
I literally like laughed out loud,
and did one of those rolling
on the floor laughing kind of things,
like not really, but...
That actually made..
>> Somersaults.
>> That was a defining moment.
I was like, yes!
Great job, Nate.
I'm proud of you buddy.
>> I also really loved seeing
when you guys have tried out
something that I showed you how to do.
I love looking at Instagram
and Twitter posts showing
projects that we taught you about.
>> Funniest comment I've ever
read is probably the running gag
of "Do A DIY lightsaber" comments.
>> Some of the comments
I thought were funny are when
you guys thought that I was Grant's wife,
or that Grant's wife was the videographer.
But it was actually
just me the whole time,
and you could see like my
reflection in Grant's sunglasses.
It was was actually me so...
>> And we're doing a giveaway.
In celebration of this
10 million subscriber milestone,
we are giving away an iPhone X to one of you.
There's only two things
that you need to do to qualify.
One, please be a subscriber of the channel,
'cause after all, it is the subscribers
who made this milestone possible.
And number two, share one of our videos.
You can go back through
any one of our 700 videos,
and just scroll down right under it,
click the share button,
and then copy that link,
and paste it anywhere
around the internet you want.
That can go on Twitter.
That could go on reddit.
It could go on Pinterest,
whatever is your favorite platform.
Go ahead and share one of our
videos, then click the link
in the description of this video to
submit your name and qualify for entry.
This phone's going to one of you,
and if you're not a fan of the iPhone X,
I have included the gift receipt
so you can take it back,
get the money back,
and buy something that you love.
>> What's up guys?
Josh here, jumping in for a quick
second to tell you about this special
shirt we're launching to
celebrate this awesome milestone.
It's only gonna be available for
72 hours after this video launches,
so, if you want one, click the link
in the description to get yours.
Once that 72 hours is up, it's over.
It's done! We're not making any more.
So, again, click the link
in the description to get yours now.
>> There are a couple things we're
hoping to bring online pretty soon.
One is bringing in a female co-host.
We're hoping to bring a female maker
onto the show to bring a little more
spice and variety,
and a unique perspective.
We're also gonna be doing
King of Random rewind series,
where we compile a bunch of our
best videos down into one video,
and for the next 10 months,
we really want to give away
some big-ticket items to you guys.
We want to give away video cameras,
drones, 3D printers, Nintendo Switch,
iPhones, Galaxy S9s, all those things.
It's going to be coming to you
as a subscriber appreciation,
because we want you to know we love you.
We really do appreciate you.
You are part of the community
that's making this whole thing possible,
and it's just one of our
ways of trying to give back.
We have done a couple of update videos
kind of explaining the transition,
but there's still a lot of people out
there wondering "What happened to Grant?"
"Where's Grant?"
And I'm here.
I'm here with my team.
>> Oh Grant!
Important question, yeah.
Are you now, or have
you ever been in jail?
>> That's a very good question.
Perfect.
Okay, great.
Alright, we're gonna jump on Instagram
here, and answer some questions live.
We are now live.
What's up Instagram?
I got Nate over here.
>> I'm in a massage
chair for some reason so...
>> I don't know.
There's probably like 30
or so man-hours in one video.
>> It's actually closer to 50.
We have about six...
>> Fifty.
>> We have six full-time employees
on the production team
working eight hours a day to make a video.
So we have a pipeline, so we're
constantly producing kind of
like production factory, if you will.
But every video has six
different people working on it,
and that's not even including me.
But it averages out
probably about 50 hours per video.
>> There you go.
>> Yeah, that's kind of a funny story.
Like if you remember back to when
we were pouring silicone on a chicken,
which seemed like a totally
random idea at the time.
I needed a lot of silicone to do that.
I reached out to Keith,
who was roommates with Nate,
and Nate was working at the
place where they do a lot of casting,
so I believe I officially met Nate when
I picked up the silicone for that video.
>> I helped him out with a little bit of that,
and then I started following
the channel more,
and when he announced
that he was looking for an assistant,
I applied along with many other people.
>> The honest answer guys is
I have been behind the production.
I've been guiding
the team's making it happen.
We literally have a list
of like a thousand project ideas
that we're working through,
so there's a lot of back infrastructure stuff
that you don't see behind
the scenes to make all this work.
To be in the videos on top
of that would just be crushing.
And I have had a lot of fun in the videos,
but it got to a point where I just
needed to step back and take a break.
Some personal time.
I have four boys and a family.
Not Nate, but he's like family.
And I just want to
spend some time with them.
My place right now is
to be a Dad, to be with my kids,
and then to guide the teams
from behind the scenes.
For me, I'd say the most difficult project
that I've worked on
was the mini metal foundry.
It's probably one of the videos
that our channel is most known for,
because at the time,
there were no videos on the internet
showing people how to melt down metal.
There were no metal foundries.
I spent six months
prototyping different recipes.
After filming, there was you know
150 hours of work between filming,
scripting, editing,
and all the post-production work as well.
So, that video was like seven months
in the making, which you know,
was one of my most difficult,
but honestly, one of the most rewarding
because that entered us into the metal
melting age, which has been significant.
>> For me, it's a little
interesting because the most
difficult things that I've worked on,
you probably haven't seen
because there are some
that I'm still kind of stuck on.
There are projects that
I'm still trying to work out
how best to make them really function.
I really like to make a sort
of DIY version of a fully
functional grappling hook launcher.
That's tough.
I've got some other ideas of what
I want to try, but I'm not there yet.
In terms of things that I've completed,
one of the most intense was
also just about my first one,
the giant like 6-foot super soaker.
The massive super soaker,
the idea where we were
copying what Mark Rober did,
and we backed it off just
a little bit so we could keep his title.
But the enormous super
soaker, that was very intense.
That was working for like 10 to 15
hours a day for almost a week.
It was just a lot of work
in a short period of time.
It was also very hot out,
but it turned out so good.
I love that thing.
>> Our production
schedule is about a month ahead.
So, what we're filming today will
probably be a released in about a month.
If you're following us on Instagram,
and watching the stories,
you might get some
behind-the-scenes glimpses
to projects that'll be put
out about a month from now.
>> The important question, yeah.
Are you now or have you ever been in jail?
>> That's a very good question.
So yeah, I know there's articles
online that said I got arrested.
I got put in jail.
I got charged with felonies.
Most of that is actually fake news.
I've been here the whole time.
I never got arrested,
never went to jail,
and most of the stuff written
in those articles wasn't true,
and the people who wrote the article
is no longer work for the company.
So, we're in the process of trying
to get that pushed out of the way,
but I will say, there were charges
pressed against me by somebody who
filed a complaint to the police,
and there was no investigation.
They just filed charges,
so I did have to go to court.
I went through the legal system,
and the charges were dismissed.
So, everything is good, but it was kind
of a traumatic experience to go through.
It ruffled our feathers a little bit.
Nobody likes being falsely accused,
and there's still stuff all over the internet,
kind of putting a little bit of a damper
on our name right now.
We've tried really hard
to do everything right.
We're still trying to everything
right, but here I am.
I mean, my position right
now is to support this team.
I mean, you're working with
some of the best guys I've ever met,
and so I'm kind
of at the head I guess.
The captain of the ship, you could say.
Just trying to steer it
in the right direction.
You know, I'm testing the winds.
I'm trying to feel how things are going,
and make sure that
what we're focusing on
isn't so much YouTube trends or algorithm.
We're not chasing views.
We're not doing anything other
than trying to produce
content that we're absolutely
passionate about and that we love.
I want to let you know that
because this is a subscriber milestone,
I tried really really hard to get a list
of all the subscribers
names to put in this video.
I've been asking YouTube for months to
send me a list of all 10 million
subscriber names,
and apparently, there have been a lot
of technical issues doing that.
We didn't realize how much data
10 million names takes up in a spreadsheet.
In fact, we tried a sample
with a hundred thousand,
and with all the rendering issues
and trying to convert to a format
that would work in videos,
we were spending days and days just
try to get a hundred thousand to work.
And to put things in perspective,
10 million subscribers
is 100 lists of 100,000,
which is incredible.
It would have taken
probably months to compile,
and make something like that work.
But it was in our heart,
in our interest
to try and put you in the video.
If I could have put your name
in this video, I would have.
Because this subscriber
milestone is all about you.
You are-- You are one of the
10 million, and that means a lot.
>> We now have ten million--
Ten hundred sparklers.
We thought it'd be kind of fun to
celebrate with sparklers,
so we picked up a box of a thousand of them.
We're gonna place them in a 1-0-M,
and light them off with a flamethrower.
[Music]
When I started this channel,
I in no way expected anybody
else's life to be better for it.
I was only doing it for myself.
But it only took a couple of years
for me to realize that there actually
are people behind the numbers.
You're behind the numbers.
You're sitting on the other
side of this computer screen.
We're having a conversation.
That makes sense to me now.
>> Guys, thank you.
This has been super awesome.
I love doing this.
I've always liked making stuff,
building stuff, and now, I just get
to do this for you guys,
and having you involved
makes it so much better.
>> I appreciate you guys.
You guys are awesome.
You guys make me be able to have my job.
>> I just want to thank you guys
so much for supporting the channel.
For liking our videos, for subscribing.
We love what we do, and we
hope that you guys love it too.
>> And where it goes
from here, I don't know.
Our mission is to continue making
high-quality content that inspires you,
and really just brings knowledge,
and the freedom and the joy
of tinkering, and making
things to the entire world.
[Music]